I'm back
Gaucho
yeah
resting
Dante is back in Devil May Cry 5 but we
played the game and perhaps the most
interesting character isn't a
silver-haired Fox Dante or his one arms
one army boy I act the edgy edge Lord
friend Nero
it's actually V black here for a nice
change the guy that Sam hates yes like a
guy used to it he looks like someone I
used to work with and this guy he used
to walk past the mirror catch himself in
the mirror and then look at himself he's
that kind of person so I see V and I'm
like you're still a douche no actually
these really cool I like that would be a
lot yeah in terms of gameplay days I
know you dabbled in Devil May Cry I
imagined this felt quite different from
what Devil May Cry is yeah it's for a
studio that's triumphantly made amazing
action games it's weird to see them make
another amazing action game then be like
we're gonna create something that's the
polar opposite to the rest of the game V
these slow fees fragile V's weak V stays
away from enemies and instead uses his
summoned nightmare Griffin and shadow
shadows the Panther yeah Griffin is
singable bird and nightmares the final
they're all references to Devil May Cry
1 characters nice to various degrees but
yeah it's like what you said and
obviously we have it's no Sun and who
has worked on various Capcom titles many
of which are some of my favorite CVS -
Dragon's Dogma there is other Capcom
games and someone at the event where we
were playing it a friend of ours Joe who
works at idea and described him as V as
playing a sorcerer from Dragon's Dogma
and it is very much like that it's a
different pace of battle it's no less
like exciting and intricate
it's just that you have to play a keep
away style yeah and that's really really
interesting for a game like Devil May
Cry but the can of that the only because
your summons can't kill enemies they can
only put them in a down state vs to kill
them with the final votes was Kane
you're spending all this time keeping V
safe
using shadow and Griffing and nightmare
to to do damage and do combos and then
you're forced into a situation we have
to finish them but you can chain
together all these finishes they'll
toast are like glowing with like a Tesla
circle and if you manage to down like
three or four enemies just dashing all
over the shops stabbing lads with your
cane is super satisfying at that point
all to hell
so the story behind him we won't get
into one because we don't expose to that
much other stage to because Matt
confusing didn't completely understand
it even the main plot
mainly because which we know we need to
get far enough I understand it was
mostly about let's try and get as much
capture of V as we can and other
characters but he he has a book he's
clearly like this mysterious figure who
knows who Dante is he knows who Nero is
he understands the underworld he's got
some place in it because enemies
reference him at some point and he
recognizes demons but that is his doll
so he moves very very slowly he doesn't
have like a super quick he can't switch
to trickster like Dante can he can't use
any other I grapple hook your arms the
black across the show he's very very
slow so kind of like as battles unfold
you're kind of moving him around in and
out of combat it's like you're a general
guiding a battle in the Alpha the
enemies are still coming for you and you
can't take very many hits so you've got
Griffin and shadow mapped two buttons
ones obviously taking the the role of
the ranged gunfire yeah and then you've
got a close up attacks Griffin has
various in both of them but have
different inputs like combo strings yeah
and they do different things so they can
still do things like crowd control air
combo do loads of like chip damage it's
done lock and that kind of stuff but
it's it's a case of like doing that
stuff well also making sure that v is
kind of like at the right range it's
weird to have micromanagement in a game
like this and and trying to if you've
got two very powerful someone's trying
to combo those two together when one is
on X and one is on Y and then you have
to move V a little way for things
because he's made of glass yeah so I'm
just picturing your head how you hold
the controller you in that point you
basically put it on your thigh I just
tap X&Y like that it's really if I use
them once for hand a PSP claw grip and
that works but unless you've played a
lot of monster on a PSP that's gonna
hurt I really felt for a moment like I
was playing guitar hero because
obviously the combos pattern and rhythm
based so X X X X X is one combo and
holding Y will
do an AoE attack so you're trying to get
into like this rhythm of tapping yeah x
and y to get these cool combos off you
like this might be this might be a song
I'm sure that it's well sound like it's
still immensely satisfying absolutely it
sounds complicated and it is and it
takes some learning to get to but that's
part of why be so interesting and it's
the same as what makes Dante near or
interesting those are also characters
that I played we played a bit of them in
the demo
Dante play is really really well he's
got all his Styles tricks the Royal
Guard Royal Guard it's still a lot of
fun Nero's kind of breakers are really
really interesting yeah his arms they
all got different properties and you can
build them into combos I was really
really getting into Nero again and I was
like oh man I'm supposed to be playing V
so I have to switch to V and play that
kind of stuff but one of the things
that's most exciting to me about Devil
May Cry 5 right now is the sheer variety
of gameplay styles that you can mess
with for people like me who and and the
many many Devil May Cry fans out there
all character action fighting game fans
out there that really enjoy I said this
before really enjoy hitting buttons this
is one of those games that's gonna make
you feel real good about sitting down
figuring out the intricacies and really
kind of making the most of the various
abilities and these seems to be really
interested we haven't even mentioned
that once you get his kind of Devil
Trigger 4 you can summon 9 9 into and he
becomes his own like autonomous
character but if you upgrade him you can
write on top of them yeah and then it
sounds crying enjoyment and then then
control him a little more so then and if
you want to build that bar up you can
play this risk/reward game where if he
pulls out his book and it slows him down
even further just writing poetry from
the book is like he's like crap
Shakespeare but he's still funny the
angel they presided on my birth said
little creature
without the help anything and that
quickly builds up his devil trigger
meter which you can expend but like I
said you're very very slow and it felt
like the moment you started to do that
enemies or like align that yeah they
really hate poetry it felt like they
were maybe it was just because I was
really aware of V being more fragile so
I felt like they were coming toward him
or but it could be that at the moment
you start doing that enemies I like up
trying to target you down target you
down well you've definitely nailed the
whole risk reward aspects like said
having the trying to avoid him from
combat and knowing when to use grab on
basically grab onto Griffin's legs and
fly away and keeping shadow in the for a
but then your demons can die so you
might have to get close and heal them
yeah and then holding trigger to read
the book it's like it's like handheld
ballet yeah it's it's really tricky once
you once you pick up V but soon as you
played like a couple of missions with
them hands just dancing over to us for
Xbox controller in it then it becomes
like we all ties together it feels yeah
I'm super super excited to play more of
the character now even though his face
still looks like that guy from working
that game and I hate him so anyways
there were a cry 5 is out on March 8th I
believe yeah in the lead up would
probably have way more coverage you can
find a written preview of the game on
the website games for the Cumbrian by
our very own mater Spinelli and you also
see some gameplay some s Wrangler every
rank gameplay v gameplay here on it was
very hard to get so in the meantime if
you've got any of your own thoughts and
opinions about V you can find us on
Twitter I'm actor more H and I'm a
regular day and we'll see you in the
next Devil May Cry fire video which I
hope is very soon
[Music]